oh all right I got a stain on my
button-down I have an interview today I
need to get out that that thing's just
like no titty do you want the job or do
you don't waste your time I need to get
the stain out
oh not gonna get it out like that dude
I'm sorry it just cost me 58 bucks what
was the thing that your grandmother used
to do the secret trap tomato juice juice
of tomahto tomato juice you sure yep
all right let me see hold on God I love
weed okay all right I don't have tomato
juice but I have Bloody Mary max ooh
that's even better the horseradish will
exfoliate stain awesome okay here we go
okay so do I do I rub it in yes rub it
in smart good it's like was it working I
don't know if it's making it look better
wait you did you applied did I put the
yeah you just watch me do the whole
thing hey just remember that that was
the wrong trick tomato juice is for
skunk sprays are you kidding
you know what I realized her trick was a
couple drops of detergent on the stain
and then you let it sit and then you
wash it normally do you have time for
that her trick was pre-treating a stain
we all know how to pretreat a stain
grandma hey turn that out inside out
sister cuz you know what they have no
choice but to show your freaking titties
and that's how you're gonna get a damn
job in this city town you think
I could go like this go like this take
the pants off I'm going to interview to
be a docent at the Frick yeah well your
ass is more powerful than your kit sorry
let me just get my bag and then I have
to go oh yeah there it is
hmm get that job edge you know what I am
gonna get that job you know I cuz I love
the Frick bend over a bunch